suben en busca de las nubes para que su
petición se escuche más cerca del cielo
es el área rural de tiwanaku en Bolivia
fuertemente afectada por la sequía
allí los agricultores alzan sus manos
para pedir el perdón de sus pecados
entre otras demandas
[Música]
hasta que llueva el aguacero la lluvia
porque para los sembrereros como el
pastor dijo que no hay lluvia en los
campos aquí en el campo no hay lluvia no
hay agua para los animales de esa razón
Nosotros le pedimos al Señor levantaron
la mano pedimos para que llueve Este es
el lago titicaca en la frontera entre
Bolivia y Perú allí los efectos de la
sequía son evidentes
está muy fuerte fuerte
no hay caso ni caminar ya creo se hace
calor en los campos pero todavía no hay
nada allá si la gente por está
preocupado varias zonas han declarado en
emergencia por esta situación que se
espera se extienda hasta el próximo año
según el servicio nacional de
meteorología e hidrología
la tierra es muy seca y no hemos podido
sembrar papa ni ñame el calor es muy
fuerte y ardiente ya no podemos
soportarlo por eso vamos todos donde hay
sombra porque el calor es muy intenso
para estos trabajadores las súplicas son
una solución cultural a un problema que
ni el hombre ni la ciencia han podido
detener el cambio climático